[Music]
on this friday night the push to crush
the curve
again new urgency to stop kovid 19 cases
from climbing
now is the time for canadians to
redouble the efforts
as the block quebecois leader reveals
he's tested positive
quebec police sent on a mission to catch
rule breakers
we have to do everything in our power to
avoid the second wave
the punishment and the concerns with
current protocols
tempers flare over lobster fishing
the escalating dispute between
indigenous harvesters and commercial
fishers
and making the leak the young canadian
rising up in the ranks
of the nba
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
lots to get to on this friday night as
cases of kovid 19 keep
inching up in parts of this country
there's debate about whether we're in
a second wave many communities have
managed to keep a lid on the virus but
some of canada's most populated regions
have not canada's top doctor says there
is still time to avoid
a full-blown second wave but the clock
is ticking
if everybody does what we know to be
tried and true measures
this thing can again be turned around in
terms of
a de-escalation here's where the
infection rates are growing fastest bc
reported 179
cases today though 40 of those are older
cases that weren't added to the data
until today
there were 107 new infections in alberta
297 new cases in quebec
and in ontario 401 more people tested
positive that's the biggest daily jump
since early june in ontario tough new
restrictions on social gatherings are
now in force in ottawa
peel region and toronto and premier doug
ford said today more restrictions
are coming into other parts of the
province to crack down on partiers who
aren't obeying the rules toronto's mayor
is getting fed up too and he warns
new rules could be on the way the bottom
line is
that the status quo has us on a path
that is
very deeply troubling and we've got to
try and arrest
that trend as quickly as we possibly can
are we at the start of what we've been
repeatedly told is coming
federal health officials say it's too
soon to say this is the second wave
but the chief medical officer for the
city of ottawa says the data in her city
is clear she says ottawa is in the midst
of a second wave because people became
too relaxed
there have been 60 new cases in three
days and high demand for testing
at one facility this morning so many
people showed up the center reached its
capacity
by 9 am another reminder today anyone
could get kovid covid19
including our political leaders black
quebecois leader e francois blaschette
announced today he's been diagnosed with
a virus
the entire block caucus is
self-isolating and so is federal
conservative leader aaron o'toole he is
still waiting for his test results after
a staffer tested positive
david aiken joins me from ottawa david
let's start with blanchett how is he
doing and do we know how he caught it
well it seems he's doing well enough
donna he did tweet out today that
he and his wife are in self-isolation at
their home in schuenagen quebec
now public health officials will try to
determine
where blanchet got the virus we do know
that he and the other block mps
held a caucus retreat recently and there
was a staff member at that retreat
who was subsequently diagnosed with
coven 19. now
esro tool no word in his test result yet
likely will not come
until saturday david a group of premiers
went to ottawa today to deliver a wish
list to the federal government what are
they asking for
well they want what they always want
from ottawa donna more money
and this time the ask is for an increase
of 70
billion dollars in federal transfers to
the provinces
for health care the federal government's
contribution levels are the lowest
they've been
the demand is the highest it's been
prior
to covet now we have an opportunity to
focus on fixing the system
nothing right now is more important to
canadians
than health care because without health
care
we have nothing if we don't have our
health
we don't have an economy now as for the
trudeau government it sounds like it's
ready to consider
some proposals but the priority
that premiers attach to uh
an accessible high-quality health care
system
is one that we share david a final
question about the covet alert app the
federal government launched it weeks ago
but it only went live in two provinces
ontario and newfoundland and labrador
are other provinces now signing on yes
so as of today
new brunswick and saskatchewan residents
are able to download and use this
app other provinces including alberta
and bc are ready to do it just working
out some technical details
but there is one holdout quebec we took
a
unanimous decision so we are four
different parties at the national
assembly in quebec city
and all of us we want to wait
because they are some concerns about
the protection of personal data now
those mnas in quebec's national assembly
apparently
have not been swayed by the verdicts of
the federal
and ontario privacy commissioners they
have no problems with the app
does not track your location it does not
track any personal info
but to be effective in helping stem the
spread of covet 19
it definitely needs more canadians in
more provinces
to download it and use it donna okay
david aiken
in ottawa thanks some breaking news from
ottawa the president of the public
health agency of canada has resigned
after less than 18 months in the job she
says
she needs a break in an email to
employees today
tina naminiowski said it was a difficult
decision but said
none of us are superhuman and she needs
to step away
she said you really need someone who
will have the energy and stamina
to take the agency and our response to
the next level
canada's public health agency has come
under criticism for its initial response
to covid19
some scientists allege their early
warnings went ignored
nami nioski said the next president will
be named
early next week
an outbreak at an edmonton school
appears to have been caused by the
province's first case of transmission
within a school two people from waverly
elementary have tested positive
a dozen students and seven staff members
are self-isolating now for two weeks
the province's chief medical health
officer says the virus was likely
transmitted from one of the infected
individuals
to the other nbc is rolling out a new
way to test school-aged
children for covid19 children aged 4 to
19 will be able to use a mouth rinse
instead of the often uncomfortable nasal
swab
kids will have to swish and gargle a
sterile salt water solution before
spitting it into a tube
the test can be done without the
assistance of a health care professional
this method is believed to be one of the
first of its kind in the world
the province hopes to eventually make
the new spit test available to
everyone quebec is getting tougher on
people who break public health rules
police officers will be fanning out
across that province this weekend
checking on one thousand bars and
restaurants to make sure safety
protocols are being enforced
though as mike armstrong explains bar
owners insist
they are not the real problem
the quebec public security minister was
flanked by police chiefs friday morning
announcing operation oscar basically
spot checks for hundreds of quebec bars
and restaurants
we have to use every tool at our
disposal
to avoid a second wave of covet in
quebec
in montreal alone 40 officers have been
assigned specifically
to look for rule breakers this weekend
things like people not wearing a mask
when walking around or
drinking while standing first time
offenders could face fines of 400 to a
thousand dollars
repeat offenders even more the law says
that you can have a fine between
one thousand dollars and six thousand
dollars
now there have been outbreaks in quebec
bars in one case a single night of
karaoke led to close to 100 positive
tests
well after that incident the province
banned karaoke
forced bars and restaurants to keep a
registry of patrons
and mandated last call at midnight
this bar owner says that's not doing
anything but costing him money
and creating another problem do you
think on the weekend they're going to go
home
they're not going to go home somebody's
going to stand up and say hey let's go
to my place let's do a party
justice minister says private parties
are another concern
gatherings with more than 10 people are
banned indoor and outdoor
the government's also looking at public
events like this baseball game
it included an on-field celebration that
seemed completely free of concern over
covet 19
including from the uniformed unmasked
police officers
who were on site to ensure people were
respecting covet-19 protocols
their chief said friday she's
investigating
what went wrong mike armstrong global
news montreal
it is september a second wave is what
public health officers have been warning
us repeatedly is coming
with schools reopening and more people
back at work the risk of covid 19
spreading goes up
as eric sorenson reports it's unclear
though what exactly
we can expect oh i think it's coming
back winter is coming
and kevin wallace senses kovan 19 is
coming back from its summer lull
everybody's going to be stuck inside
it's going to be a lot harder marta
pastor says it's already different
as long as we have these 40 year olds
and under
that don't comply young people are
getting covet 19
at a much higher percentage now than
last spring luckily not as many need to
be hospitalized
at midweek hospitalizations in the four
biggest provinces were rising
but far from over taxing a health care
system with thousands of beds
still when case numbers rise worse
outcomes often follow
if numbers do remain going in the wrong
direction and people are then point and
say well the hospitalizations are fine
it's only a matter of time before that
indicator catches up
a resurgence of covet 19 should not come
as a surprise
as early as last april before the leaves
were out
public health models suggested what was
ahead don't expect that curve to flatten
out entirely
what with getting back to somewhat
normal life you can expect to see some
waves in the fall and possibly the
winter so
fast forward almost five months after
the mass infections in the spring after
getting back to somewhat normal life
over the summer
now we are seeing again a rise in cases
up
58 percent over a 14-day period in
september
but a second surge will not be a repeat
of the spring
many things have changed some for the
better hospitals have
improved care and better drug treatment
long-term care facilities have
reorganized staffing
and access there is more testing and
more people wear masks now
we're definitely more prepared now than
than we were back in the spring
not only do organizations know what they
have to do public health organizations
health care organizations the government
is more familiar with it we have a lot
more experience with this
and people are more understanding of
what they need to do but some risks are
increasing too
we're socializing more now not less
we're sending children to school instead
of sending them home
and contact tracing is still lagging
behind and we're all kind of fed up with
the whole routine
we're acting like cajun tigers you know
there's a lot more at stake than just
people
being tired of being at home a new surge
of covert 19 seems inevitable
but what remains unknown is how bad it
will get who will get it
and what the next curve will actually
look like eric sorensen global news
toronto one thing we do know long-term
care homes in canada have been the
epicenter of the covid 19 outbreaks here
most of the deaths in canada
were people living in long-term care and
in ontario right now there are still
22 long-term care homes with active
outbreaks
as michael couture reports many
facilities aren't ready for another hit
in nearly three weeks there have been
eight deaths related to covet 19
at this ottawa long-term care home 54
patients and staff have also tested
positive for the virus
at the extendicare west end villa in
ottawa
numbers that prompted ontario premier
doug ford
to call out the operators of the home
they're a good company
but it took one long-term care worker to
go in there
that was infected and it went through
there like an australian bush fire
in response extendicare said they are
testing their employees
regularly blaming testing backlogs in
ottawa saying quote
if we don't receive the results fast
enough we cannot effectively cohort
and protect our people canada's chief
medical officer believes the country's
long-term care homes
are more prepared for the next wave but
i certainly remain concerned
that probably not enough is being done
in
every facility and every single
of these homes need to really show up
their measures
including staffing long-term care
facilities across the country
struggled with keeping workers during
the early months of the pandemic
and some say little has been done to
address it
we need their help in mobilizing an army
to come in
not the army but a new army of
workers quebec's response was to
increase wages and fast track training
for personal support workers
which led to the hiring of 10 000 new
people
premier ford says ontario support
workers are underpaid and overworked
but so far the province hasn't boosted
wages
i'm all over health right now to get
this through treasury
as soon as possible we can attract more
people
provinces won't be able to count on
volunteer resources from hospitals and
school
boards like they did in the spring
leaving some front line workers
at a loss i don't really know what more
we can do than to hope and pray that it
won't
be as bad as it was the first time
around not exactly reassuring as the
country braces for a second wave
michael couture global news ottawa
a fight over lobster fishing coming up
the contentious battle between acadians
and migma
in nova scotia
there's a dispute going on in nova
scotia that has deep roots
it's about who is entitled to fish for
lobster
and it's pitting indigenous harvesters
against commercial fishers
many of whom are of acadian descent they
all want the same thing to use plentiful
lobster grounds to keep their families
financially afloat but agreeing on how
to do that
is not just contentious it's turning
violent ross lord is in sonyaville
nova scotia ross what's been happening
well donna this dispute is a
long-standing conflict and
no one seems to be able to reconcile it
for nova scotia sebagon agony first
nation these moments are historic
issuing seven licenses to start its own
self-regulated lobster industry
my son is a fisherman but also
you know it's his children you know
our grand my grandchildren you know
that's their rights
and if we don't protect those rights and
assert those rights today
you know what's going to be left for
them but after migma fishers dumped
their traps
their lines were cut this as hundreds of
commercial lobster harvesters
protest what they consider an
out-of-season fishery
they should fish when we fish
commercial boats took turns skirting the
tied up indigenous boats
at the nearby weymouth wharf
confrontations turned bitter
are on site in an effort to maintain
order they have their treatment
which gives them some extra stuff
whether you like it or not that ain't
going anywhere
all right signed the new fishery to
coincide with the anniversary
of the supreme court of canada's 1999
marshall decision
that ruling upheld the treaty rights of
indigenous harvesters
to fish outside the commercial season
for a quote moderate livelihood
but 21 years later there's still no
common understanding of what that means
what is a modern life that's got to be
discussed more than anything because
i've seen you causing a lot of trouble
at gutter wars
i think it's the minister that needs to
come up to a solution
because both both parties shouldn't be
here fighting
in a statement fisheries minister
bernadette jordan says
she's deeply concerned about escalating
tensions
jordan says she's working with first
nations leadership to find a
collaborative path
but she says until there's an agreement
with dfo there cannot be a commercial
fishery
outside the commercial season the
sebagon eggety chief suggests
he doesn't trust the minister the
fishers minister is heavily influenced
living in a fishing village yourself so
maybe
maybe she should be replaced with
somebody that's more of a neutral
understanding of how it's going to work
new lobster traps have arrived
signaling sebagon agony first nation is
determined to forge ahead
the rcmp say they've arrested two people
both for assault
and they're investigating other
complaints including mischief and
uttering threats
an rcmp statement says members will
remain in the sonyaville area
on land and on the water to keep the
peace
donna all right ross lord in nova scotia
tonight thank you
still ahead the risk those fighting
california's wildfires
take
you're watching global national
those fierce wildfires raging along
america's west coast have claimed
another life this time
a firefighter he died fighting the
massive el dorado wildfire in
california's san bernardino national
forest
the blaze erupted after a botched
fireworks display at a gender reveal
party
on the labor day long weekend he is the
26th person to die
in the fires that have consumed
california this summer
from kitchener ontario to the nba finals
next canada's unstoppable
shooting star
there is one player right now who is
considered the spark fueling the denver
nuggets thrilling run in the nba
playoffs
jamal murray single-handedly launched
the team in tonight's western conference
finals
showing up stars like kawhi leonard as
mike draulia explains being
born and raised in canada might have
something to do with it
jamal murray was always good at
basketball but in the last few weeks
he's developed an exciting new skill
making overconfident sports pundits eat
their words
everybody counts us out and it's just
fun
it's just fun to silence everybody we
love it growing up in kitchener ontario
not exactly a basketball mecha you could
say murray got used to it
i remember i think i found him at 14 or
15
and i remember calling our national team
coach at that time in that age and i
said look i just found the guy that's
going to start for us
and sure enough as an 18 year old murray
was starting for team canada
how he got to be so darn good is a tale
unto itself
when other kids were watching tv or
playing video games
murray's dad roger had him playing
basketball or working out
and in the winter he dribbled a ball on
ice rings and did push-ups in the snow
willingly you would never say that um
you know
small's dad's overbearing a soft-spoken
smooth guy
right real dope guy one of the guys he
doesn't really put himself above anyone
else in the crowd
all that hard work has now thrust the
younger murray into his starring role
leading his underdog denver nuggets into
a clash with lebron james and the la
lakers
he's a ways to go before anybody starts
comparing him to retired star steve nash
but canada's best active player might
also be the hottest player on the planet
right now
he says excelling at basketball has been
his singular goal in life
but he's made room in his off seasons to
give back to kitchener
last year he built new basketball courts
in an area that badly needed help
yeah the best sports mate is amazing um
and those kids now have a safe area to
play
and that's why i had growing up but
that's what that's where i had a court
like that
and that kept me out of trouble a lot of
times and as you can see he rarely shows
his emotions in interviews
but as his profile grows so is his
confidence
and murray has embraced the message of
black lives matter
the deaths of brianna taylor and george
floyd hit him hard
and he's using his voice and his shoes
to draw attention to the issues of
equality
and racial justice it doesn't take me a
23-year-old to recognize that that's not
right that
should be in everybody's mind um if you
don't see it that way then
there's a problem with you and it's
becoming clear that if you don't see
murray as an ascendant superstar
that's on you too mike drolite global
news toronto
and that is global national for this
friday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is this freshly cut alfalfa field
in ponoka alberta
i can smell it from here thanks for
watching rosh hashanah jewish new year
begins this evening to those of you
observing this special time we wish you
all the best
bye bye
you